die cdu erlebt gerade was passiert wenn
einer der in erster linie informatiker
und musiker ist und bei youtube videos
dreht sich an einer generalabrechnung
mit der regierungsarbeit versucht über
dreieinhalb millionen mal aufgerufen
selten hat ein politisches video bei
jugendlichen so ein großes echo gefunden
in deutschlands klassenzimmern wird es
wie selbstverständlich herumgereicht
das ergebnis macht die partei nervös
auch weil sie sich schwer tut mit einer
angemessenen antwort mehr von florian
hahn und simon pfanzelt ein 26-jähriger
youtuber greift an
ein 26-jähriger cdu-politiker soll
antworten
es könnte das ungewöhnlichste duell in
diesem wahlkampf werden
ein café in aachen hier treffen wir
rieso denn unter diesem künstlernamen
auftreten möchte ein profi youtuber der
sich sonst mit musik und comedy
beschäftigt am samstag postet er ein
video dass parteien in berlin in aufruhr
versetzt titel die zerstörung der cdu
weil sie etwa beim klimaschutz versagt
habe sich selbst ziele setzen und nicht
einhalten was das sind für inkompetenter
schütte ich hatte einfach den drang in
mir dass ich das ist dass ich leute auf
klein wollte dass ich mit diesen themen
mehr auseinander setzen wollte also
natürlich natürlich bietet es sich an
sowas zu machen wenn gerade mal 1 55
minuten lang wettert rieso nach eigenen
angaben unabhängig von parteien oder
organisationen gegen cdu csu und spd
der ton der ab die liste an quellen lang
für alles zeigt der beläge in den
letzten jahrzehnten hatte die cdu die
meiste macht und das ergebnis davon ist
dass sich viele sachen für die reichen
finanziell ziemlich geil entwickelt
haben und für alle anderen nicht so was
nicht in seiner argumentation passt etwa
das rekordtief bei der arbeitslosigkeit
fällt unter den tisch
die wut geht viral dreieinhalb millionen
klicks auch wenn nicht alle das video
komplett gesehen haben dürften
man muss ein solches video ernst nehmen
und das zeigt sich hier eine veränderte
medienwelt im grunde genommen gilt wir
sind auf der auf dem weg von der
mediendemokratie alten typs hin zur
empörung des demokratie des digitalen
zeitalters und hier kann jeder mitmachen
sich zuschalten
wie reagieren auf die lautstark
geäußerte wut mit jedem klick wächst in
den parteizentralen die unruhe verlieren
die etablierten eine ganze generation
erst der protest auf der straße ob gegen
die urheberrechtsreform oder gegen die
klimapolitik und jetzt so ein video
heikel kurz vor der europawahl
die reaktionen auf rieso zwischen
umarmung und angriff bis hin zur cdu
vorsitzenden
ich habe mich gefragt warum wir nicht
eigentlich auch noch verantwortlich sind
für die sieben plagen die es damals in
ägypten gab der familie dort vieles und
er bleibt ungenau er liefert einfache
antworten auf komplexe fragen und das
ist nicht wirklich seriös attackiert
wird in dem video war nicht nur die
union auch die spd kriegt ihr fett weg
insofern ist es wären mit dem
klammerbeutel gepudert wenn man dieses
video nicht ernst nehmen würde und es
werden ja auch wirklich gesellschaftlich
wichtige themen angesprochen klimaschutz
zum beispiel geht uns alle an die
parteien aber müssen dahin wo erst
wähler sind ins netz auf youtube und das
dauert bei der cdu haben sie zwar ein
video mit ihrem jüngsten abgeordneten
angekündigt mit philipp am tor doch am
abend ist das immer noch nicht online
ein 26-jähriger youtuber setzt parteien
unter druck und zeigt nebenbei wie
politische debatten heute auch ablaufen
[Musik]
und das ist weit mehr als eine
auseinandersetzung zwischen youtube
community und regierungsparteien das ist
ansporn und herausforderung zu aller
erst mal für journalisten die bilanz von
politischem handeln dessen folgen und
verfehlungen darzustellen in
zusammenhang setzen und zwar nach
journalistischen standards und mit
journalistischem handwerkszeug und dann
das wird die größte herausforderung auch
wirklich alle in diesem land erreichen
auch die die sich ihre informationen
mittlerweile fast ausschließlich über
youtube holen